تبحث السلطات في ولاية فيرمونت في
احتمال أن تكون هذه جريمة كراهية
وفقًا لما ذكرته الشرطة في برلينجتون، حيث
كان الطلاب الفلسطينيون الثلاثة يسيرون
في أحد الشوارع في طريقهم لزيارة أحد
أقاربهم يوم السبت عندما
واجههم رجل مسلح بمسدس، جميع
الطلاب الثلاثة  تم إطلاق النار عليهم الآن وقت
إطلاق النار، وقيل لنا إن اثنين من
الضحايا الثلاثة كانا يرتديان
وشاحًا فلسطينيًا تقليديًا، وقيل لنا إن
صورة الطلاب الثلاثة تم
التقاطها في وقت سابق من اليوم يوم السبت، حيث تم القبض على جميع
الضحايا الثلاثة  تم علاجهم في
مركز فيرمونت الطبي، وقيل إن اثنين منهم
في حالة مستقرة، أما الثالث
فيعاني من إصابات أكثر خطورة الآن
وفقًا لمعهد
فهم الشرق الأوسط، وهي
منظمة على اتصال
بأسرة الضحية، وتم
التعرف على الطلاب على أنهم يبلغون من العمر 20 عامًا.  تم إخبار تاسين علي
أحمد كنعان عبد الحميد وهشام
عورتاني أن الثلاثة تخرجوا
من مدرسة خاصة في الضفة الغربية
قبل مجيئهم إلى الولايات المتحدة للالتحاق
بكليات مختلفة.
قال عم عواني، وزير التعليم الفلسطيني الأسبق، إن العورتاني كان يزور
جدته هنا وهو الآن محامٍ.
تمثيل أحد أفراد عائلة الضحية
حول سبب تأكدهم من أن هذه كانت
جريمة بدافع الكراهية، حيث اقترب منهم المشتبه به
وأطلق النار عليهم، ولم يتعرضوا للسرقة،
ولم يتعرضوا للسرقة، لقد كان أه
مستهدفًا أه أه إطلاق نار مستهدف و أ  استهدفوا
جريمة مستهدفة وكانوا
يرتدون المقهى المعروف
أه في المنطقة أه تعرفه لأنك
فلسطيني تعرف أن هذا
رمز معروف جدا إنه قماش معروف جدا
أه القماش أه رمزي جدا
للقضية الفلسطينية
الثقافة والتاريخ الفلسطيني، فحقيقة أنهم
كانوا يرتدون هذا ثم وقعوا
ضحية مطلق النار يقودنا إلى
الاعتقاد بأن ذلك لعب دورًا
لعبت هويتهم دورًا أه في
استهدافهم ليلة الأحد أمام حشد من الناس تجمعوا
خارج قاعة مدينة بيرلينجتون
ودعا الشرطة إلى التحقيق في
إطلاق النار باعتباره جريمة كراهية الآن في وقت سابق من
اليوم، قال رئيس الشرطة إنه لا
يمكن لأحد أن ينظر إلى هذا الحادث ولا
يشك في أنه ربما كان
جريمة بدافع الكراهية، وقال مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي إنه على علم
بالحادث  وهم على استعداد
للتحقيق في إطلاق النار على كارلوس سواريز
سي إن إن
أتلانتا